there's nothing better than starting the
day celebrating women being with your
sisters what does it mean for you to be
it simulus in my advocacy in my passion
really is around women and girls it
really is about investing in women and
girls if we have won any chance of
progress in this world and any hope
honestly because there's so much
potential that we neglect that when we
neglect girls and women so the idea of
investing in their passions and their
abilities and in tomorrow where we have
more women leaders and more positions of
power and decision-making
I mean that's what it's all about I mean
that's that's the core focus you know I
just I just came back from South Africa
a global citizen festival and yes and it
was an amazing event I got to you know
speak around women and girls issues
there and meet some astounding
astounding young women who are braver
than I've ever imagined I've gone
through things I couldn't imagine and
still rise and go forth and I really
believe that a lot of the healing the
world needs is in the bosom of women now
it was just announced that Lupita and
viola are going to star in a movie about
I don't want to get this one because
it's kind of like the real-life story of
the dorm Elijah the Amazon women yes oh
yes well I just I just saw it yesterday
I just saw like the article about it
yesterday that I think is phenomenal
there couldn't be a better pairing
together telling a real-life story of
powerful women absolutely I mean it's a
beautiful thing and more and more of
this is happening and it's really really
exciting we need to see more women
stories being told being greenlit there
is absolutely no - - it's and I think
that that's something that is being
slowly more and more realized and proven
without a shadow of a doubt family will
be back together today yeah you guys
will be together um you know I just love
you guys together we're gonna get the
Golden Globes nominations on Thursday do
you think about it do you have a little
bit of butterflies and what would it
mean to hear the movie and you all being
recognized it would be amazing you know
I mean we've been through an amazing
astounding year that we could never have
dreamt of or imagines you know the way
the
movie has been embraced and the way
people have responded to it in ways that
that's always a part it's the sort of
art I've always wanted to be a part of
which is impactful and groundbreaking
and tell stories that I've always
believed have been able to be told even
as a playwright which is you can put the
African front and center you can put the
black person front infant center you can
create excellent stories about people
that are not of the quote-unquote
mainstream and you will find that the
mainstream is actually many things two
things we had infinity war we saw what
happened did you see any part of
Avengers or set did you see a part of
the set did you shoot any scenes where
are you absolutely nothing of what
you've asked that I can answer but it
was also announced that Ryan's coming
back from Black Panther - do you guys
get to sit and maybe talk to him and get
and you know have some ideas back and
forth about where the story came I think
it's early phase but I mean honestly we
we entrust our visionary with that role
you know what I mean he's a he's a very
stunning collaborator as well but you
know he's in his process till he's what
willing to open that up and that's what
makes him such an amazing leader comics
sure he eventually becomes Black Panther
I would love to see that Oh leave it to
him he knows what he's doing I'm very
sure of that
[Music]